okay we literally have seen people argue
that it is okay to crowd together in
houses of worship churches because Jesus
is protecting the people from
coronavirus remember this lady a couple
of months ago six weeks ago driving out
of this Ohio parking lot is a woman who
just attended a church service with
dozens of other people including
children can I ask you about your
decision to go to church to be inside
that building I wouldn't be anywhere
else
aren't you concerned you could in fact
other people if you get sick inside I'm
covered in Jesus these people it turns
out not only was that not true but
churches while trying to get coronavirus
stimulus money are often staying open
causing new outbreaks of disease New
York pastor Fabian arias has a parish
that lost 44 people to coronavirus
that's not cases 44 deaths to
coronavirus bishop paul eggin Steiner
from an Evangelical Lutheran Church
Network says that the pastors in their
network are reporting in some cases 25
to 50 percent of their congregations
have coronavirus in the south of the
United States we've seen more of these
huge evangelical churches stay open and
there's a whole bunch of examples
Kentucky there was an outbreak that
started and then but moved from the
church to GES aviation plant in
Madisonville 70 infections have been
traced back to a church in Sacramento
California the full list is not so
important but the point is churches have
been huge epicenters of outbreaks some
churches not all to be super clear some
churches have been the loudest advocates
against the stay at home orders wanting
exemptions from the large gathering bans
for example and yet at the same time
they want coronavirus money houses of
worship have received hundreds of
millions certainly
maybe even billions of dollars under the
Paycheck protection plan and the reason
is because searches are being treated
like any business or nonprofit that
needs funding so understand the
hypocrisy here churches want to be
exempt from stay-at-home orders because
they say we're not like any other
business or organization but they say we
are just like any other business
organization when it comes to PPP funds
now the truth is more complex many of
the churches that are seeking funds have
shut down or doing only online stuff
many churches in Massachusetts for
example fall under that umbrella so I am
not individually saying every Church is
hypocritical because they are all
against shutdowns and all taking PPP
money that's not the case many of the
churches that got PPP funds are Catholic
churches and many Catholic churches have
been closing in accordance with state
guidelines but the special treatment has
to stop guys in the eyes of the law and
under government we've already said
churches likely shouldn't be nonprofits
and churches probably should be paying
property taxes now I have no problem if
the church has a school or a daycare
something that is truly a traditional
standard nonprofit
I'm fine looking at exemptions there but
the general blanket idea that by saying
you are a place of worship you pay no
taxes it has to end and in addition in
exchange for the privilege of not paying
taxes houses of worship are not supposed
to be political and often they are
rarely are there ever repercussions so I
just want consistency if you want to be
treated just like any other business and
get your PPP money and all of that well
then you don't get to say we are
different and we get to stay open as as
if we were an essential business why
would that be the case if you are
special and you get to stay open no
matter what and you get to not pay taxes
why do you also get the PPP funds and
then more urgently because really you
know I care more about lives than the
money component the issue of funding
taxes all of its important but it's not
urgent the issue of churches as a locus
for coronavirus outbreaks that is
both important and urgent very much so
and I don't know at this point what can
be done there there are actually
churches that are deliberately being
defiant when it comes to coronavirus and
staying open and it has to stop because
it's spreading infection and as a result
it is spreading death if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always struggling to find the
time check out one of my all-time
favorite apps called blink it's blink
Isleta consume an entire book on your
way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blink Asst blink east
has books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but you
can try it totally free and get 25% off
a subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video